I'm looking at your stamp the huncle for
your name and it looks like so it looks
like it's gene was something right what
would I don't know how to say your last
yeah right I can't I don't know I like
one of your 50 languages I can't I can't
pretty good I can't spot the other
character what is your choice well you
know it's because it's kind of old it's
kind of the ancient calligraphy older
calligraphy so it's way as in way phone
like bravery or valor my father was he
was a nationalist so it basically says
my paternal name and then national valor
national valor at this altitude I can
run flat out for a half mile before my
hands start shaking you know I also
opposed to personal
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by trunk club I hate
shopping with a passion going shopping
for fun to me is like let's go do our
taxes I don't get it it's something that
I have to do but I don't like it at all
and quite frankly I'm not good at it I
always end up looking like I'm
colorblind or homeless or something like
that so ROI really sucky and as a result
I decided to try trunk club and I did to
dislike it quite frankly but here's how
it works and here's why I'm now a huge
fan and just as a prelude the items that
I kept from them I've had more
complements from random women on like
t-shirts and shorts and these funky
green shoes that I got than ever before
which proves that I don't know what I'm
doing and they do you go to trunk club
comm forward slash Tim you answer a
couple of questions then you get
assigned a personal stylist so mine was
Robin then they send you a trunk full of
awesome stuff that they predict you will
like and look good in based on your
sizes preferences etc that they've
covered in this short phone call it was
really short to the point then this
trunk is delivered to your home it's
free of charge both ways so you only pay
for clothes that you keep if you keep
none of them that's fine you mail the
whole thing back with a prepaid label
they even include tape to shut the box
and you're good to go cost you nothing
there's no ongoing subscription this is
not a subscription service so only when
you ask for a trunk you will get a trunk
and I expected to keep maybe two items
out of eight you know I didn't want a
thousand things said to me so I got
about eight things sent to me and expect
it to keep two because they give you a
preview online to show you what's coming
and then keeping for and I've been
traveling with those I have very
minimalist luggage but I've been
traveling for a couple of weeks and I've
brought everything with me because it's
been so multi-purpose and so well
received it's kind of blown my mind
quite frankly so trunk club.com forward
slash Tim you get premium clothing great
advice for zero work so it's a great
trifecta and the way they make money is
really easy I mean they buy high quality
clothing at volume and they just charge
you the normal retail pricing but
obviously they buy it
a cheaper price so there's no tricks no
hidden costs it's really easy to be the
best-dressed man in the room or on the
street so their entire styling service
is free for now like I mentioned check
it out trunk club comm forward slash Tim
they also have club houses so you can
check that out which is pretty cool so
trunk club comm forward slash Tim and
you can get a trunk filled with sweet
clothing very easily that will make that
ladies want you and make the men want to
be you it is a good ROI and for someone
who's always hated fashion now I can
actually look fashionable with next to
no time expenditure so pretty sweet
trunk club com forward slash Tim check
it out this podcast is brought to you by
mizzen and main don't worry about the
spelling all you need to know is this I
have organized my entire life around
avoiding fancy shirts because you have
to iron them you sweat through them they
smell really easily their
pain-in-the-ass mizzen and mane has
given me the only shirt that I need and
what I mean by that and Kelly Starrett
loves these shirts as well is that you
can trick people they look really fancy
so you can take them out to nice dinners
whatever but they're made from athletic
sweat wicking material so you can throw
this thing into your luggage in a heap
or on your kitchen table like I did
recently and then pull it out throw it
on with no ironing no steaming no
nothing walk out you could probably wear
this thing for a week straight or make
it your only dress shirt and take it on
trips for weeks at a time never wash it
it will not smell you will not sweat
through it you got to check these things
out so go to 4-hour workweek comm all
spelled out four hour work week comm
forward slash shirts check it out 4-hour
work week comm forward slash shirts and
you'll see some of my favorite gear
including the one shirt that I've been
traveling with what's up my little
munchkins this is Tim Ferriss welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
I've been waiting to record this intro
and this goddamn garbage truck keeps
backing up so it we're gonna roll
with it and make that part of the
ambience the Tim Ferriss show is where I
attempt to deconstruct world-class
performers whether they are chess
prodigies hedge fund managers athletes
artists comedians celebrities actors you
name it scientists we dig into every
and the reason is you find that there
are say morning routines
there are meditative practices there are
types of nutrition and training that
transfer across all of these domains
it's pretty amazing that you find a
common toolkit for excellence and in
this episode we have Jimmy chin and I
remember at one point Jimmy was kind of
introduced to me conceptually by someone
who said if Chase Jarvis the world-class
photographer and Laird Hamilton arguably
the biggest big wave surfer of all time
that's the biggest the best big wave
surfer of all time had a love child it
would be Jimmy and I was like what the
hell does that mean well Jimmy is an
artist and a professional athlete often
at the same time as a Nat Geo a National
Geographic photographer he is
participated in and documented
breakthrough expeditions around the
planet from climbing first ascents in
the Karakoram to skiing first descents
in the Himalayas put another way he is
one of the few people to both climb
Everest to the summit and then see it
down from the summit which is bonkers
most recently he filmed and directed an
incredible feature documentary called
Meru Emmy are you which is in theaters
right now and won the 2015 audience and
warrant at Sundance so what is Mara put
this in perspective for folks in the
high-stakes game of big wall climbing
the shark's fin on Mount maro is I
suppose the ultimate prize Everest is a
cakewalk
by comparison sitting at the headwaters
of the Ganges River in northern India
the shark's fin has seen more failed
attempts by elite climbing teams these
are the best of the best over the past
30 years than any other ascent in
Himalayas or the Himalayas as they say
and this movie is a story of one group's
journey to conquer it and there are many
mishaps along the way and it's a
white-knuckle quest of friendship
sacrifice hope and obsession how the
hell Jimmy captured it on film while
simultaneously risking his life is
impossible for me to fathom but we dig
into it so in this episode of the
podcast we talked about his origins
training nutrition gear and tackling
Meru of course
which just really blows my mind and I
don't say that lightly so suffice to say
if you want to benevolent king of the
ass go see Mero that's your assignment I
saw it with my family and for probably
15 minutes afterwards all they could say
was whoa whoa
Oprah nari and my friend was holy
under my breath muttering you know 20
times every hour or it's it's really
mind-boggling what Jimmy pulls off
it's amazing terrifying and inspiring
and inspiring at the same time so
without further ado please enjoy my
conversation with the incredible Jimmy
chin Jimmy welcome to the show thank you
nice to be here it's it's really been an
interview that I've struggled with how
to tackle because when I watched is it
marrow or meru I don't know how to
emphasize the name of this I say Mara
Mara so it was basically 90 minutes of
saying oh my god oh my
god oh my god so I feel like
most of the questions that I would have
formulated during that time might have
been hijacked
but we're gonna of course talk about
that and many other things but when you
are asked by people what do you do how
do you answer that because you have been
described by a friend of mine as as the
love child if there were one of Laird
Hamilton and Chase Jarvis which I
thought was hilarious
since both have been on both have been
on the podcast both amazing world-class
performers in surfing with Laird and
many other things and then photography
with Chase and I don't want the image in
my head of them actually doing anything
sexual but how do you answer the
question what do you do because you do
so much yeah sorry I was picturing
something terrifying actually but I feel
like chase would you would really get
the worst end of that you know that's a
question I get asked often and it's you
know it's kind of amazing that I still
don't have a very good answer for it
I generally break it down into three
pieces I'm a professional athlete I am a
photographer and I'm a filmmaker and
that's kind of / you know my sources of
income so I guess that's that's the best
way that I can describe what I do and an
athlete kind of entails everything from
corporate speaking to you know
endorsement of product or a brand
ambassador or working on RD&D with
designers on jackets you know so that
they kind of spread through a lot of
different areas
when I say athlete and then photographer
is of commercial and editorial work and
filmmaker is kind of the same you know
documentary filmmaking and and
commercial work as well now for those
people who may not be familiar with your
work what what would be the Jimmy chin
highlight reel look like when you're
introduced by a friend at a party who's
had a couple of drinks and so is very
enthusiastic when they want when they
want to really catch someone's attention
with some of your accomplishments what
are the things that they throw out I'd
say
oh wow I mean you mean flattering ones
or unflattering that's true yes my
friend Jimmy what one of my buddies does
as a side note he's from New Zealand so
he loves doing this to people but he'll
run up to me at parties when I'm when
I'm talking to someone I want to make a
good first impression on and they'll go
hey buddy has a syphilis going anyway so
oh sorry to interrupt it'll run off so
I'm referring that I'm referring less to
that type of shenanigan and more to the
flattering stuff when he wants to
impress someone I I would say you know I
think it would be hey this is Jimmy he's
the National Geographic photographer
he's climbed in skied Everest and he
just recently you know won the Audience
Award for his film at Sundance that
would probably be the quick and dirty
the quick the quick and dirty top three
what is a first descent and what is a
first descent thing climbing and skiing
respectively because you've done both is
that right yes I guess to give it some
context those are the descriptions of
what professional climbers and skiers or
snowboarders do because really you know
when you're when you're a professional
climber or a professional skier you are
often trying to do firsts things that
have never been done before and you know
you make a career of trying to do first
a sense or first descents and and and
really that's kind of like your legacy
too so for instance if I show up in a
mountain range in the Karakoram in
Pakistan and I go to the trango towers
which is this beautiful range of big
Alpine walls and in Pakistan I can look
at the mountain and the mountains and
I'll see these prominent lines you know
and and you'll either have a guidebook
or you'll be with somebody that can
point out these lines and say that prowl
on the Great trango first descent by you
know so and so and so and so you know
marks in it and now it slow or and
so it's kind of like your legacy but
it's also your inspiration to in a lot
of ways and then if you're a skier you
can go up to Alaska and you know you'll
see these big intimidating lines and
they're related to somebody and they'll
be out Doug Coombs you know one of the
great skiers of our generation that well
he did the first descent and they're
important because they you know they
represent a person's legacy in a way but
they also inspired somebody and so much
of and they had they had to have a
vision to do it because usually each
generation you're trying to push the
kind of boundaries of what's possible by
doing these certain lines and of course
they get harder and harder her you know
a generation after generation where
where am i reaching you right now where
are you in the world I just got back
home in Jackson Hole Wyoming and you
have a you have a very busy have a very
busy schedule ahead of you but if if
you're looking back retrospectively at
suppose that's redundant but you get the
idea at your three silos and they're not
really silos because they're so
intertwined the the photography the
athletics and the climbing and and
alpine sport and then the filmmaking if
you could only be remembered for one of
those three which would you choose and
why
oh boy that's a tough one I don't even
know if I can answer that because
they're so important to me there's
crossovers within the communities and
I'm not trying to totally dodge the
question but you know my peer group I
think of my peer group when you asked me
that question and there are so many
people who I respect and appreciate in
each kind of category I guess you could
say and they're all equally important
and inspiring to me so I don't know that
I have I guess that is the answer is
that there isn't one that I would prefer
to be remembered by or I I'd love to be
remembered by all of them
if you let me really rephrase what if
you had to stop doing one of them gun
against the head had to choose one which
would it be higher making this tough
there's a lot more where that came from
yeah I'm sure you know I would probably
choose oh man I mean climbing and skiing
have provided so much inspiration for
the other two and the passion for the
other two in a lot of ways were rooted
in in being in the wild and the
experiences that I had and have in the
mountains and in the ocean surfing or
you know I'm I'm a pretty physical
person and you know I I just find such
great joy in doing those things so okay
I guess I'll say the the climbing and
the skiing the surfing the athletic side
that's what I'd pick okay that's what
you'd pick to keep that's what I'd pick
to keep now let's talk about the
physical side of things cuz I know the
people listening are very interested in
your training regimens and things like
that and we're gonna rewind the clock at
one point and talk about your upbringing
and background a bit but a mutual friend
of ours sent me this paragraph and I'd
love to dig into it a little bit his
training regimen is alien example to our
car to car ski laps on the Grand Teton
question mark exclamation point question
mark so I want to come back to the ex
I'm not sure what that is
he'd be in town having a coffee after a
grande lap by mid morning hexam guides I
don't know if that is but in Jackson
Hole lists this as a two day ascent and
many would consider the seminal
achievement of their mountaineering life
it's a standard work out for him
so I want to get to I want to drill into
this exactly what is a two-hour car to
car ski lap I think that hours are
probably wrong I've never done it in two
hours car to car and I don't think
anybody has that I have done so
sub-10 maybe maybe even around six hours
and I can't remember what the fastest
time I'm not one of those people that
records my time every single time I go
up and do something like I have a
general sense and it's more just for me
to gauge you know where my fitness is at
but a car to car time let's say it's six
to eight hours somewhere in there is
basically you start in the valley floor
and if you didn't start a stopwatch
you'd start it when you left the car and
then you'd climb up the grand and then
you'd ski back down it back to the car
and then you'd stop the clock so car to
car you know I think one of the times
that has been kind of recognized was I
when I was training to just ski Everest
I was kind of doing laps on the grand I
would do it a few times a week and at
one point towards the end when I was
really fit I climbed in skied the grand
and then went over and climbed and skied
the middle and then went over and
climbed and skied the South Teton you
know back to the car and I think it was
sub 10 hours so I can't remember exactly
but something like that um and for me to
think about it now and I'm like wow that
was that's pretty fast because I don't
think I could do that right now you know
and could I do it again at some point
maybe but yeah that's how I trained
because I didn't you know I do have to
train in the gym now probably more than
I ever had to before and I don't
particularly love it because the whole
point for me was that was being in the
mountains and I didn't necessarily
consider it just training because I got
to be in the mountains and I got to
climb and ski and breathe and push
myself and look at the starry sky early
in the morning or watch the Sun Rise you
know I mean there's so much beauty in
that when I'm in a gym feels a little
lacking but
I have to do it now more is now is that
a is that a function of age or what is
the reason that you have to spend more
time in the gym I mean some people who
I've seen in their kind of Arc and
they're kind of like career arc as a as
a professional alpinist or ski
Mountaineer they've moved more into the
gym because there's less exposure to
risks right and you know I mean it is
kind of a statistics game more time
you're out there the more risks you're
exposed to it catches up to you so there
is that part for me that's not
necessarily the case it's more the fact
that I'm traveling a time I'm married to
you know my wonderful wife who lives in
Manhattan and you just don't get those
like full days where you're like oh you
know and and and to get in the mountains
you have to wait for the right
conditions - so if it's storming you
can't just go you kind of have to wait I
don't have that luxury it's like okay I
have to train I have to have a certain
amount of consistency to stay in
shape what does your week of exercise
look like currently and and let's let's
separate that from kind of launch time
with the new film and so on and just
think about a a non crunch period like
that although I think you probably have
a lot of crunch times yeah from the
looks of it but what what is it we
assuming that you're in Wyoming what is
a week of training look like for you and
and the more specific the better because
I I love it and I know the people
listening would really enjoy it
okay well it's hard for me not to think
and maybe this will be helpful to you
like I can think about what it used to
look like
in my mid to late 20s when I could just
go and then also right now but right now
a week at home you know I'll usually set
aside two full days
if I'm a home for seven days so two of
the seven days I'll set aside four full
days and one full day depending on the
season you know would be to go on if
it's a winter it's a huge ski tour or
you know climbing and skiing one of the
peaks and the Tetons as like one of my
big days and then or what yeah I guess
in the winter would be two of those it
would be like ski something big in the
Grand Teton National Park and then
another big you know full day skiing
backcountry at the resort or ski touring
up on Teton Pass which is this great
backcountry ski area ski access area and
then the five days in between you know
I'd probably be working most of the day
and I would just get like one or two
laps up on the pass which is like a
approximately 1500 foot hike and then a
ski down and I would probably do that
once or twice if I had a little bit more
time in the afternoon probably throw in
some yoga and there once or twice a week
or just some stretching once or twice a
week as well and what type of gym work
would you be doing in that week or would
you not be doing much gym work I
probably wouldn't be doing much gym work
it seems like in the summer time there's
probably a chance I would do two days in
the gym which would probably be kind of
core stuff it'd probably be like core
and and and yoga of some sort and when
you say core to get really specific how
long are those workouts and what's what
might a hypothetical or real sequence of
exercises look like for you probably if
I'm lucky and I have somebody that I'm
training with that will run me through
some workout there's you know sandbag
get ups which is it's like a Turkish
getup using a sandbag or if different
exactly it's like a Turkish get sandbags
you doing that with one arm it's just
one of those sandbags with kind of the
handles on them yeah and you throw it
over your shoulder and you basically get
up so to get up with a sandbag on your
shoulder that sounds
miserable exactly not that much fun and
holiday what type of kind of rep is set
scheme are you doing with that it
depends you know I think I'd probably be
doing like sixty pound sandbag and I
think it's like five to ten on each side
and then I would go to do like a series
of sit-ups or some sort of you know leg
lifts or something like that or you're
hanging off at something and doing leg
lifts and then planks essentially kind
of three core workouts back-to-back and
you do like a whole round of them got it
so you'd be C do sort of sandbag get up
some type of leg lift plank and then
repeat that sequence yeah and in the
winter I might even if there's like a
climbing station where there's just like
a wall there to hang off of I'll do a
core workout and then I'll just get on a
wall for about four or five minutes at a
time overhanging wall and just kind of
work out my arms just so I have some
semblance of like keep some semblance of
my climbing capacity and and really
that's one of the hardest things for me
because you know I supposed to be a
climber and most of the climbers like
serious professional climbers they just
climb year-round and most of the skiers
ski year-round so they go to South
America and ski during our summers but
you know I'm kind of switching back and
forth and they're they're kind of they
don't complement each other that well
because skiers get these huge legs and
that's like the worst if you're a rock
climbers like to have big nations
exactly and obviously really strong
forearms and finger strength does
nothing for your ski right that's like a
constant in a battle yeah it's like
being a benchpress competitor and a
competitive cyclist yeah yeah well I
mean not to say you're doing much bench
pressing but the point being that the
yeah the exercises do not necessarily
transfer
from one to the other when now you have
and this is this is talked about in
marrow which I enjoyed incredibly I mean
I recommended it to 500,000 people or so
via this newsletter that I send out
every Friday called five bullet Friday
yeah I found a extremely inspiring but I
want to talk specifically about it's not
really a biathlon it's kind of like a
triathlon but in an unconventional sense
and so much as so Mara I guess it's the
shark fin am I getting this right
the shark's fin requires it's it's sort
of it's defeated some of the the top
climbers and Alpine ists for 20-30 years
because you can't just be good at big
wall climbing and I guess for people and
please correct me if I'm wrong this is
just I'm trying to give people who
aren't familiar with this stuff some
context a big wall you could think of
say El Capitan or some of these shear
surfaces in Yosemite as a big wall you
can't just be a good big wall climber
you can't just be a good ice climber you
can't just be good at any one of these
disciplines you have to be world-class
at all of them and what I'd love to ask
you is for instance in the case of rock
climbing and when people think of saying
indoor gym or just climbing outside
bouldering or doing top roping or
whatever or or lead climbing if they're
if they're more advanced
what are some common novice wastes of
time or they spent or or mistakes and
I'm just going to kind of hit each of
these disciplines for people who are
eager to practice this stuff all right
so let's just if we look at rock
climbing first and your own development
and looking back and knowing all the
people you know what should novices do
more of and less of I'd say in terms of
technique a classic mistake that
climbers make when they first start is
that they think it's all about having
these big arms and upper body strength
and it's really actually about the
footwork and balance and keeping your
weight over your feet and so
it's the classic scenario where you have
like the big burly guy who's about to
start climbing and then like the petite
you know woman that you know is a little
bit intimidating intimidated and and
taking like you know just there's a
different attitude towards that you know
and then the guy gets up there and is
trying to muscle through this climb and
use like his big burly shoulders that
he's been lifting you know building in
the gym and he can't get 20 feet off the
ground and then you know the small
petite woman who maybe did ballet or
gymnastics gets up there and floats up
the thing and then the guy is totally
destroyed right multiple levels
you see that all the time because the
woman is a being smart and she isn't
leaning towards muscle it's more about
you know how she stands on her feet and
and is you know just being much more
thoughtful about how to do how to climb
this thing and so I don't know if that
necessarily answers your hello it's
helpful I mean I've I've watched women
in the gym and they're consistently I
mean the higher level climbers better at
keeping their arms straight and keeping
their bodies over their feet or at least
using their feet to their advantage what
if you were training someone in rock
climbing how would you have them
practice for the first say two weeks
would it be on the bouldering wall would
they be doing top roping would they be
incorporating other things like
slacklining if you really wanted to lay
a very very good foundation what would
you focus on in those first two weeks I
would probably get them on the
bouldering wall just to get familiar
with you know moving around and not
being so caught up in like the rope work
and all of those things and just getting
that body movement that muscle memory
for kind of just moving around on a
vertical surface and then you know then
the top roping I would you know bring
that in
getting them confident with tying the
knots so that they understand the
systems because so much of the fear that
comes in climbing is often perceived and
a lot of you know what you do as a
climber as you're managing fear and and
I think that you know I often talk about
managing fear by recognizing the
difference between perceived risks and
real risks so when you teach somebody
about these systems and they understand
it and they're like oh this is a safety
system and this is how it works you can
help alleviate some of the fear of the
climbing and that you know the the
height so then I would just take them
you know top roping and get them
familiar with with climbing up a bit
higher and using that kind of technique
that they've been learning on the
bouldering wall as well let's talk about
gear for a second because I know people
have asked me to ask you what type of
when you're in the gym or just not doing
cold weather stuff when you're just
working on climbing what type of shoes
do you wear
for normal rock climbing yeah I guess it
would just be climbing shoes you know
what brand yeah yeah I normally climb in
five ten they're known for having the
best and a sticky rubber any particular
model I've climbed a lot in the Anasazi
for more like everyday climbing and for
backcountry skiing and ski touring what
type of gear do you use I use inna fit
boots and Madinah fit bindings and then
skis over the last few years
usually on our modest skis or Black
Diamond skis when you're doing downhill
I would imagine the gear change is quite
a bit but I don't know I'm not outside
of my area of expertise yeah it's funny
because I just you know I wear I use a
lot of different brands based on like
what do they have so I've skied laying
boots and Armada skis for many years
that's kind of like my on resort kind of
setup and then
that's the main that's the go-to yeah
and when you're doing this training and
going doing laps right of various types
and you're out there for five to ten
hours all right are you what does your
nutrition look like if anything I mean
what are you bringing with you in terms
of water and food I'm bigger days in the
mountains this is not an expedition but
let's say I'm going up to climb and ski
the grand or I'm doing a long run across
the Tetons or something in the summer
it's usually you know I have cliff shots
cliff blocks I also use a lot of hammer
nutrition stuff that I think triathletes
and endurance athletes use so there's
heed which is a great carbohydrate drink
that you know isn't over flavored and
pretty easy to use and then I like to
have real food as well so it's usually
like a ham sandwich or PB&J
or a couple of them I also take dura
lights which is basically an electrolyte
pill hammer nutrition makes I bring a
lot of lifesaver mints lifesaver meds
wild lifesavers yeah I don't know I mean
when they're night they're like a little
nicety to have in here on a long run or
big day out I have a terrible - sweet
tooth so it kind of helps the fattest so
do you bring life savers on your bigger
expeditions as well like on Mara did you
have a stash of life savers absolutely
and I I noticed of course and a lot of
people have noticed you have earbuds in
a lot when you're climbing where I would
imagine exercising let's just when
you're on these these bigger expeditions
what are you listening to and actually
just in Baretta of The Glitch Mob wanted
to ask this specifically he was easily
yeah he's been on the potty he's been on
the podcast before and so he wanted to
know like what do you listen to how do
you use music when climbing
etc I'd love to just hear what is that
what is in your ears well a couple
things
I don't usually climb like when I'm
actually leading or if I'm belaying I'm
not listening to like a ear pod but on
expeditions I definitely on the tracks
in you know where it's four or five days
of trekking I'll be listening to music
and yeah certainly sometimes when I'm
bouldering or or touring like up into
the mountains just to ski something I'll
have them in but when I'm actually like
when it gets real like there's real
climbing a real skiing happening I
definitely am not listening to music at
that point yeah when you're trekking in
what's what are some favorites it's
funny that for huh who's amazing and I
love The Glitch Mob I mean we definitely
listened to The Glitch Mob I'm Mara
and despite like the weight limitations
that we put on ourselves we brought this
teeny little Nano and a little micro
speaker with like solar speaker and we
had Glitch Mob on there that's awesome
I've been a huge fan of them for a long
time and we had everything from you know
classic reggae Jose Gonzalez Eddie
Vedder and the classics to you know like
Led Zeppelin Neil Young and then I don't
know it's it's it's really across the
board I listen to rock um yeah I mean
long trips I usually have pretty good
mix of music but glitch Marvin Jose
Gonzalez we're definitely playing a lot
I'm on our merry expedition when you
look back at all of your experiences and
I'm sure you get approached by many
wannabe sounds bad but aspiring
Mountaineers and I apologize that I'm
not sure if Mountaineer is
interchangeable with alpine climber with
or Alpine estai I don't know the vocab
but for people who look at your life
outdoors and envy that and want to spend
more time outs
and want a goal of some type let's just
assume that they are mid-30s used to be
pretty athletic maybe competed as an
athlete spend a lot of time sitting down
but want to reverse that and need a goal
of some type what would be some some
decent sort of goals to put in the
calendar in terms of certain a sense or
summits or anything like that just let's
assume that they're they don't have any
any real technical training to speak of
at this point yeah I think there's a
couple avenues to come into it
I think Noel's is a good way to come
into it the National Outdoor Leadership
School based at Lander Wyoming they have
I think they have a few adult classes
another great way to come into it of
course - if you're a professional and
and you want more one-on-one kind of
instruction I think the best way to do
that is to come into it by hiring a
guide and you know I think a great many
Expedition for someone our goal would be
to climb the Grand Teton because you
come into it you learn the basics of
rope work you learn you know how to
belay and you go climbing for a couple
days down low so you're comfortable with
the rock climbing and the systems and
then you get to go up on the Grand where
it's a bit more Alpine and higher
altitude and and then you get to climb a
mountain and you know a lot of people
like a typical good client who's getting
a lot out of the experience what will
have that climb under their belt and
then you know the next year they'll call
the guide if they got along with them
really well and had a good time and say
hey let's do something else
you know and that guide will probably
come up with another really cool idea
and maybe that's climbing some a harder
route on the ground or go into the winds
the Wind River Range or you know there's
these ways to kind of continue to to
progress as a climber but then you also
have like the safety of this like very
knowledgeable guide how do you how would
one go about finding
good guy - there's certain websites of
resources that you'd recommend yeah I
mean I think you can go in Jackson for
climbing the ground if there's two
outfits one is exha mountain guides and
the other one is Jackson Hole mountain
guides and you know all of their guides
have gone through courses and then
definitely been in the mountains a lot
and so you can go assign one and know
most of the guys I know are great and so
that's one way to to go into it you can
also do this kind of thing in Yosemite
or in the Sierras as well you know and
that's that's another place to go yes a
great documentary called valley uprising
about the last whatever it is 50 years
in Yosemite big wall climbing and it
kind of traces everything from the very
early days all the way up to Alex
Honnold right as that name say his last
yeah and and and and a number of mutants
like that the question that I wanted to
tackle next is going way way back where
did you where were you born and raised
so I was born and raised in Minnesota
Mankato Minnesota which is basically
this small farm town with a small
University in it and had your parents
been there had your parents been there
for multiple generations no no my
parents were both from China and my
mother was from higher being no I was
just going to say they had to be from
some cold-ass place like Harvey together
Minnesota well my mom was you know and
she came from like this really
progressive family my my grandfather was
like trained in Western medicine and the
doctor and my grandmother was like she
spoke multiple languages she's pretty
progressive for her time she was
apparently an actress in Japanese cinema
I don't know how that worked out that's
out there that's yeah and so she came
from that that kind of a world and then
my father was from the south in Wenzhou
and he was from like a really
traditional
a military family and it's very unlikely
that those two would have met in China
but you know in that era both of them
left both of their families left China
during the Communist revolution ended up
in Taiwan and when they both went to the
United States for university and met in
the States they apparently just you know
they moved to Chicago after they got
married didn't like the city and heard
that Minnesota was apparently a good
place to raise a family so they moved to
Minnesota and worked at the University
in Mankato and that's where I was born
but both of them worked at the
University yes what did they do there
they're both librarians that's
fascinating and what what were some
defining moments in your childhood like
when you think back to how you were
raised and growing up in that
environment what would you if you depict
a defining moment in your childhood what
would what would one be well I grew up
you know this is their they were very
kind of stereotypical Chinese parents
they were very focused on academics and
kind of these extracurricular activities
so I started playing the violin when I
was three and a half and you know that I
realized swam yes I swam competitively
from when I was like seven through high
school and then I studied martial arts
from as long as I can remember from my
dad so my mom was kind of like pushing
the violin side my dad was pushing the
martial arts side and they both kind of
agreed I'm a swimming part but my life
was consumed by these things because I
was basically either practicing the
violin going to swim practice or going
to the dojo you know and competing every
weekend played in the you know Youth
Orchestra and and I was studying a lot
and so I was pushed pretty hard but I
was also really motivated you know I
wanted to do well in these things they
were
confining in a way and so when I found
skiing there's a little ski hill behind
my house that was my reward if I did
well and everything else and I still
remember I skied in jeans and a jean
jacket and froze my ass off this little
like the Andre Agassi evasion kids in
Minnesota which I was like the only one
by the way not many Asian kids uh how
would you now you have your owns your
own small child now am i right yes what
are you going to do differently if
anything in raising your child compared
to your parents and that's not meant as
a criticism of your parents I'm just
curious what you'll what you'll
definitely borrow and what you think
you'll do differently yeah I've been
thinking about that a lot you know I
really had to go against the grain my
parents were not into the fact that I
finished college and decided I was gonna
go I basically told my parents I said
hey look I discovered climbing as well
and in late in high school and I was
obsessed and I told them hey I'm gonna
take a year off after college instead of
looking for this you know this new
career I was supposed to go on because I
mean they they really were your three
options are lawyer doctor executive you
know and okay so when I told them that I
was gonna like live out of my car for a
year and I the way I framed it was like
I just got to get it out of my system
and then I will happily shoot a powered
career somewhere well one year turned
into two two turned into three I lived
out of the back of a little blue Subaru
for seven years till I was 28 climbing
and skiing and doing odd jobs like
shoveling roofs in mansions and Jackson
you know we'd have to do rope work and
like yeah I did random stuff to to make
it work and so they were very well they
were mortified my mom would say well of
course we're worried there's no word in
Chinese for what you do you know like
how what are you doing and I couldn't
imagine a different life because I just
it was so powerful for me to to do that
and it was tough you know I had a lot of
doubt about it but it didn't help
obviously that you know every time I
called them they were like what are you
doing you know um but so what I took
away from that though is that the
foundation that they set for me in that
sort of discipline and even though it
wasn't like I found the martial arts I
did eventually really love it swimming
it was just I did love that physical
aspect of like competition - and just
like pushing as hard as you can like
improving incrementally and
understanding what it takes to kind of
progress I think playing the violin was
incredibly you know I'm so thankful that
it you know I picked up the guitar in
college it was really easy to pick up
and music has been a big part of my life
and so those aspects of my upbringing
while at points in my youth I hated them
but there's so much appreciation for it
they also you know raised me to speak
bilingual they would ignore me if I
didn't speak to them in Chinese because
they knew I was gonna learn English but
at home it was only Chinese and you know
so I I got to grow up with another
language and when I was younger I was
like my parents are crazy nobody else
makes their kids do this stuff but I
really appreciated it so I don't think
I'm necessarily dictate you know you
have to do this and this and this
I'm certainly gonna share the things
that I love with my daughter marina and
if she you know enjoys them or becomes
passionate and that could be photography
too you know I'm gonna share those
things with her and I I think I'll have
the capacity to recognize whether or not
she you know finds one of them really
appealing and in a lot of ways it's also
selfish because I want to be able to be
with my daughter and surf with my
daughter but I want her to find
something that she's passionate about
and I've told myself this and I don't
know whether or not I'll be able to
execute I'm hit that you know you know
to wrap my head around like it could be
something totally different than what
you expect and you're gonna have to
embrace it and and give her all those
opportunities that she needs to to
pursue whatever that thing is and maybe
it's knitting who knows you know and
it's I mean it's like my mother and my
mom and dad did that with me quite a lot
I mean they didn't have the the same
focus on music although I took music
lessons I was a chronic quitter with
music but did expose me to a lot we
didn't have a lot of money but was
constantly exposed to things outside to
different types of activities and then
they put whatever muscle they could
behind helping me and my brother to
explore those things and I'm really
grateful for that and I had a number of
mentors but this isn't about me I want
to ask you about your mentors and I only
know about a few of them now Conrad
Anker
is in the film and if you're listening
to this you have to go see marrow it's
time extremely well spent and it's a
beautiful film and a terrifying film and
it points a hilarious film but I wanted
to talk about and ask you about someone
I'm less familiar with
because we you we've mentioned
photography but haven't really touched
on your start and I'm not familiar with
it so it's hoping you could maybe tell
the story of meeting is it Galen role as
that how you pronounce his name
yeah it's Galen Rowell Rowell there we
go and yeah could you explain how you
became exposed to photography and then
how you met hi Kailen
well I began so I never studied
photography I didn't take any classes in
photography I actually had a friend who
wanted to be a photographer showed me
how to use his camera and take a while
we were on a climbing Yosemite and I
took a photo with it and and he was
trying to sell his photos it was slides
at the time and he sold it for sold one
photo and it happened to be mine for
$500 and and he still says I started
Jimi's career which is true um and he
went on to do great things in his field
as well but I it was so funny because in
a way I'm embarrassed to say it like I
didn't come at photography from this
inspiration of creativity and in art you
know I came at it from being like oh you
know I live out of the car my car five
hundred dollars I can live for basically
two months you know I'm like man I only
have to take one photo a month and I
could do this for the rest of my life
you know um
that was like my 20 year old self
thinking obviously my I've evolved from
there but you know I so I picked up
photography then and I was very
fortunate to start shooting right away
for commercial clients just because I
was surrounded my peer group where all
these climbers like Dean Potter and Stef
Davis and Timmy O'Neal and cedar Wright
and amazed they all became you know
famous climbers and and I started
shooting for Patagonia in the North Face
right away because
they wanted someone they didn't have to
worry about when they were up climbing
and and I could climb and I would shoot
with him but Galen came into my life
when I started looking at a lot of
different photography and he embodied
like this form of adventure photography
that was very participatory he was
shooting from like the inside out as
opposed to from the outside in what do
you mean by that
where he's part of the team and and
climbing and he was a very talented and
visionary climber I mean he has first
ascents all over the world God have done
and he was appear with his subject
matter exactly and you know I related to
that and at one point you know I saw
these photos of Conrad and this other
climber Peter craft in Pakistan in this
unbelievable Valley and I was like okay
that is the end game like if I'm gonna
commit to being a climber and I'm gonna
be in Yosemite climbing I'll cap wasn't
the end game that was like where you cut
your teeth you took what you learned in
Yosemite and you go to a place like this
place you know in this picture the
high-altitude big walls of Pakistan and
so I'm like 24 maybe and 23 maybe and I
decide okay well the one guy who's gonna
know how to get there is this guy Galen
and so I drove from Wyoming to Berkeley
where his his gallery was and I showed
up at his outfit Lee California yeah and
I walk in the office you know and I'm
like the receptionist is there and she's
like kind of help you and I'm like yeah
I'm here to see Galen and she's like and
you are like well I'm Jimmy chance she's
like okay and she goes upstairs she
comes back she's like you know he just
came back from this huge shoot there's
all these photo editors there he doesn't
have time to see you today so I was like
well that's cool do you mind if I hang
out
and look around a bit she's like that's
fine just so I sit in the lobby that day
the rest the afternoon
kind of like moping around and looking
at pictures and the place closes and I
leave and I come back the next day and
same thing they're like oh it's you
again I'm like yeah is he around and
they're like mmm
not really so basically I do the same
thing on Tuesday do the same thing on
Wednesday do the same thing on Thursday
and if I then they're kind of like dude
what's your deal and one of the guys
they're a little bit younger was like
man what are you doing and I'm like I
just want to meet the mean and I have a
I just need ten minutes of its time and
he was you know they're like well maybe
come back tomorrow
so show up on Friday same thing and at 4
o'clock on Friday afternoon Galen comes
down and
he's like so you must be Jimmy and I
said yep and he was like okay well you
have my undivided attention for the next
two hours what can I help you with and
floored two hours that's legit yeah well
bad and I was like oh my god it's Galen
you know yeah sure so then I get up
there and I'm like kind of embarrassed
and she I was like look I want to go to
this Valley and so he pulled down to
slide trays and started showing me
pictures and I needed an objective and
because I was trying to write grant
proposals and I didn't even know where I
was going and he was like well here you
go and he literally pulled the slide out
of the tray and was like this is your
objective and it was these two huge
towers that had their unclimbed and
that's that's not something you give up
normally you know you mean actually give
me
you mean information was yeah not not
not something you know if you're a long
time climber and you kind of keep those
close to your chest there's not that
many of them out there you know right um
so he gave those to me he gave that
slide to me put me in contact gave me
the contact for his fixer on the ground
there as your superior very influential
first Pakistani to climb Everest and
then we walked around he said the second
hour he walked around he had the Siamese
prints and we I got to walk around these
tables with his most iconic prints and
he got he told me the stories about the
prints and I mean I was floored as
almost speechless at this point and then
he sent me out the door and said good
luck and you know what you got to
promise me that you you will take a
camera and that was sent and I had just
taken that photo that had sold as well
it's ironic you know I bought a camera
and put my put in an expedition together
to that Valley and that was the first
expedition that I went on and then fast
forward I think it was
for years and I went on my first
National Geographic expedition with
Galen to Tibet and got to watch him work
you know day in and day out for tube to
months you know I mean it was hugely
influential on multiple levels what were
some of the things that you learned from
him whether those are you know
principles techniques sort of
philosophies sayings anything probably
the most important thing was just how
hard he worked I mean he was always up
before sunrise to to make sure that he
was in position to get the best light
and he and he ran and he moved so much
and when you're on those kinds of
expedition team plateau unsupported you
know average elevation 17,000 feet and
you see unsupported what do you mean
then that there is no we are carrying
everything on our back-end note no
Sherpas no and there no cars
yeah no no people that bring something
to you if you needed it I mean we're in
the one of the most remote high deserts
in the world and those trips are all
about efficiencies you you you never do
anything unnecessary because you know
that you need every single ounce of
energy to accomplish the goal and yet
here he was running up to this you have
to understand he's 62 when I went on
this trip with him and I was 28 you know
and he was climbing up these ridges up
to the side and shooting back down to
get this perspective and then going back
down to his stuff and he'd be way behind
and then he have to catch up you know
and then he would get ahead and shoot
shoot back and like just to see what it
took
how committed he was and just how he
lives through the lens it just show you
know sometimes mentors don't have to say
anything you know it's just you spend
time with him and that is the greatest
gift you can have and and sometimes it's
just
knowledge that you're doing something
right it's not saying like you have to
do it this way or that way sometimes you
do but you know what I've learned so
much from my mentors is like that was so
meaningful to me is like I'd take an
initiative and they would kind of give
you the nod like you're doing the right
thing and that was a powerful lesson in
terms of what it is to be a mentor you
know because that was so powerful for me
to see that and say oh wow like I I took
a stab at something I took a risk and
they're acknowledging that it was a good
risk and it gives you so much more
ownership over it to sometimes you know
so Conrad in the film does this a lot I
mean he gives the nod to you quite a few
times and I won't give away any uh any
sort of punchlines or key moments that I
think people should just see in the film
but the there is one moment and that I'd
love to to dig into fear as it relates
to this so there's a moment and I'm
blanking on what it's called oh the
house of cards is that it right holy
I mean can you describe this to me
and then the question is that you
describe it for people what this house
of cards is and then when you feel fear
if you do I assume it's there but what
what is your internal dialogue what do
you say to yourself before you tackle
something like that so if you could
explain the house of cards to people and
why it's called that yeah I had to
really like stop drinking my beverages
in the theater because number one it was
cold by my like very limp-wristed
standards in the theater but I was also
like my bladder was was I was having
sort of system sympathy fear just
watching this so what is the house of
cards so the house of cards is one of
the pitches which is you know
essentially a rope linked on a climb
where I had to go up through this
section of rock which were basically
these delicately balanced
giant granite slabs that you know
probably each weighed 10,000 pounds
apiece and and I had to move climb
through them without ever over waiting
any portion of my body or else you'd
peel one off and the whole thing would
collapse like a house of cards
and as John so eloquently states in the
film it would floss the whole team off
the mountain so it was fairly well we
call it delicate climbing it's like that
you in the understatement of my
podcasting career words so far yeah
delicate and blinding yeah yeah and so
it was my lead and you know with so much
of the climbing on expeditions like this
you have to really sometimes you just
have to take a really deep breath and
believe in yourself that you will make
the right decisions and you're gonna
draw from all your experience it has to
be tempered because it can't be
overconfidence and there's this fierce
concentration your world becomes so
small in those moments and in a way also
very expansive in the sense that you're
so focused on the moment so so focused
on the moment and and that's part of I
know you're probably gonna think I'm
completely insane but I mean that is
part of the appeal of climbing is like
nothing takes me out of thinking of my
emails or her you know all these random
trivia T's in life that we usually think
are so important you know nothing takes
me out of that more than than than
climbing and there's this kind of fierce
concentration and I I was on that lead
for six I think it was actually eight
hours but you know it it happened when I
finished it and I got to the anchor and
I was ready to come back down it felt
probably more like 45 minutes you know
and it just you you have to have that
belief that you know you can do it and
you really draw deep into your
experiences and I've been in those
situations before to where it was in a
way you you you train yourself to
function in very high stakes high
consequence situations and so you draw
from that place yeah I would imagine
it's a process of sort of fear
inoculation and exposing yourself to
that in sort of a progression of
difficulty right like you said people
take their experience on El Cap and then
translate that into the bigger game
which is in Pakistan or wherever they
might be talking about objective so you
said I needed an objective in your
conversation with Galen so I sent a text
here - your wife has an old old friend
and we were going back and forth about
various things catching up with life and
then I was talking about the film and I
put Jimmy is a beast
CAPITAL LETTERS period good lord
a real man in a world of quote guys end
quote refreshing to see now I'm not
hitting on you although probably seems
like I'm hitting on you I do think that
there's a malaise among many males in
say their 20s and 30s who are spending a
lot of time sitting down in front of
computer screens and they just don't
feel as sort of manually literate or
physically capable as their forefathers
and I do think that causes a lot of
problems haha so what would what what
speaking of some objectives right what
are some skills or that you think every
man should have or things that every man
should have done well first of all I
first I'd like to probably address the
fact that I personally
feel doubt and inadequacies all the time
I think people is you know after being
on tour with his film people are like
wow you know you must not feel fear you
must not have any doubt and and I don't
necessarily want to project that image
because you know I think that you know
I'm fearful all the time and you know
among my peer group I'm always like oh
my god I'm such a wimp you know these
guys this guy is doing this and this
guy's doing that and I'm like gosh I
don't know if I could do that you know
and and I just want to put it out there
that that's okay and that's normal and
that's and I'm okay with that but in
terms of skills like I mean if you're
out there and you know I can't speak to
all the different things out there I
mean I don't know but let's just say
you've had let's pretend because no
one's listening it's just the two of us
we've had three glasses of wine each
yeah and then I asked you this question
okay that's a good way to put it
well if you don't do this then you're a
total candy-ass right well there's some
skills I wish I had you know that I
think would be good but mountain
climbing is a great objective because
there's so much around it there's like
the organization there's like the vision
there's like the camaraderie when you
get your friend to go up there with you
there's learning technical skills
there's opportunities to learn about
yourself and push yourself it's physical
its cerebral so you know it might be
unfair coming from a mountain climber
but that I think mountain climbing can
do a lot for you and and you get to
being outside in these beautiful
landscapes which is a huge part of the
inspiration for me I'd say writing well
has been extremely important not that
I'm a great writer but I think it's an
incredible skill set
you need in whatever aspect of life you
have what has helped you improve your
writing the most weather lessons or
teachers or books or practices or
anything for me it was probably early on
was reading a lot and then finding you
know favorite writers and examining why
I like the writing and I know it's so
cliche but I mean I freaking love to
have anyway you know I mean ways great
yeah and in the same in the same way
that's that's really how I developed my
photography I didn't have anybody
teaching me it but I looked at a ton of
photography and I started to break down
why I liked certain photographers and
then you know there are certain
photographers that helped shaped you
know how I looked at my shooting so you
know it's a it's like studying other
other other great people in the field
has always been a great way for me to
learn who are some of your other
favorite authors oh man that there's
I'll throw out one just up just to buy
some time I don't know if you've ever
read coming I think it's coming into the
country by John McPhee MCP hae about his
his travels in Alaska but I think it won
the Pulitzer but just incredible writing
as it relates to his outdoor expeditions
ya know I've definitely read McPhee
Jonathan Franzen recently you know Jon
Krakauer is a friend of mine but I've
always been like amazed at like how he
approaches his work
they say Jon Krakauer did I just say Jon
no you said you should you should
Krakauer yeah okay so I read recently I
think I just finished Jon Krakauer's
book Missoula and I was just really
impressed with how he basically in a way
changed how he wrote to address the
subject in the in the most powerful way
that he could and being able to morph
that way is really
was really impressive to me when you I
mean the you guys obviously know one
another you've met a lot of successful
people but when when you think of the
word successful who is the first person
who comes to mind and why you know who
I've really been just endlessly
impressed with is Yvonne Jannard I'm not
a go to you yeah yeah I mean obviously
he's known for founding Patagonia but
it's it's like he he's found he's like
hacked the system somehow you know I
mean he's known for founding Patagonia
but he also is I mean he's really
started 1% for the planet and he started
you know Patagonia land trust and he
found a way to you know have a
successful commercial endeavor
understanding that there's necessary
evils that people are still gonna buy
stuff you still have to make clothing
because people have to wear clothing but
yet you know his approach is like we're
gonna make things that are best thing
possible and we're gonna do it as
ecologically sustainable as we can you
know and he's also led this incredible
life of adventure and you know he's
inspired me in so many different levels
and I've been really fortunate to have
spent some time with them he's a he's a
sharp guy he's a sharp dude and his I
remember his book let my people go
surfing I think is the name of it yeah
had a really big impact on me when I
first read it so I want to say about ten
years ago it's actually I keep it in my
closet sort of so that I see it every
morning when I get dressed it's sort of
on that on the top shelf next to a few
other books what is the book that you've
given most as a gift
she's probably two one is musashi Oh
fantastic yep love that book and the
other one is probably the this book
called the guide to the eaching by Carol
Anthony which was given to me as a
freshman by one of my comparative
religion teachers and I've pretty much
traveled
since I've had a copy with me
somewhere and it's just an interesting
take on an interesting perspective the
eating is eaching it's I mean it's like
a Rorschach test in a way right or a
mirror or both it's yes I took an entire
class in college on the eating and the
interpretation and use of the eating in
the historical context very yeah very
fascinating and I could have put it
aside for a very long time and now it's
very timely that you bring it up is I
should I should go order this because
I'm getting back into examining sort of
how to draw a value out of that the the
author is Carol Anthony yeah and it's
funny because I don't consult it you
call it consulting the eaching very
often these days I almost carry it
because I and I if I see it I've looked
at it so often so many times over the
years that like this is how I just look
at it and I'm like okay I kind of know
what the answer is
dilemma having you know that's awesome
that's super cool yeah I'd love to talk
about your morning rituals on your ideal
morning what is the first you know like
60 to 90 minutes of your day look like
when you wake up what are your morning
what morning rituals are important to
you etc besides getting up and looking
at my Instagram what well what time do
you wake up around 7:00 7:00 8:00 8:30
if I've kind of gone out late and or
stayed up late I work late and it's a
terrible habit like I I'm usually
hammering emails until I fall asleep
which is awful I've been trying to train
myself to to just read which works every
so often but in the morning in an ideal
morning I would get up and
the first thing you know one of the
first things I would do would be to sit
down and try the meditative and and
maintain that practice I'm not great but
it's always been beneficial when I've
had some consistency in doing it
what type of 20 shits okay sounds like
our Transcendental Meditation or no yeah
kind of a form of it and you know I kind
of looked at and played with different
forms of meditation but that that one
that that form is kind of a type that
I've been doing lately but I reach I
usually it's I don't even want to say
that it is TM because it's more it's
like a conglomeration of different
things that I've learned and and thought
about and then it's breakfast which is
usually toast and jam or or granola and
bananas and yogurt something like that
or smoothie and then I just open up my
laptop it's so boring
and trying to view and saying to myself
oh my gosh I got like hammering this out
because what I'm trying to do is get as
much done as I possibly can in the first
few hours in the morning because my head
is clear so that I can go run outside
and do something in the afternoon God it
says is the morning then that is when
you're mentally sharpest and you want to
then gently snoc stuff out before lunch
so that you can get outside and run yeah
do it whatever activity yeah partaken
yeah do you uh do you drink no not very
much no mainly because I'm Asian and I
get a headache and all asleep
hey you guys you guys are not not great
at processing ethanol you guys but no no
but I do I do I have been known to drink
and yes it's not uncommon for me to have
a few drinks if you walk into a bar what
would you order I usually order a beer
in nurse it for a long time
tequila is probably where I go if I'm
going out to a pretty good day right
yeah tequila yeah there's some there's
some good stuff out there they casa me
go see the casa that I grow nice there's
uh I was never a tequila fan because it
turned me into a complete lunatic and
that only changed when I stopped mixing
it with other things so unless unless we
count club soda club soda is a fair
mixer but if I combine tequila with
anything else it's just a recipe for
disaster and my experience yes good
tequila yeah what $100 or less purchase
has most positively impacted your life
in the last say six to 12 months yeah I
mean a classic thing I always buy one of
the like niceties that you might get is
this lip balm blackjack lip balm black
hang yep all right no it's Jud it's
actually called Jack Black Jack man lip
balm got it and I've taken it on every
expedition I've ever been on and it's 25
SPF and it's like one of the few things
that keeps your lips from cracking on
like a really bad tough expedition so
that's always nice to have
yeah that's simple Jack black lip balm
uh uh I may be by probably not doing
anything strenuous enough to warrant lip
balm but I bet that is probably an
indication that I should get out and
move my ass around and more strenuous
environments if you could have one
billboard anywhere with anything on it
what would it what would it say
uh that is the task or I'll give you
another one you can choose from
well it's funny because I the two things
that came into my mind like immediately
was one was like chill
the other one was get after it
oh yeah I have met you seconds I can see
the conflict well maybe you put them in
different places yes maybe and and I
think that's probably yeah that's kind
of representative of the way I function
I tell people I'm the laziest motivated
person that I know because I'm out of
the hurt they just you know want to just
completely kick it back or else I'm
going a hundred and fifty miles an hour
right trying to hit a first ascent
yeah involving in the house of cards and
other things what advice would you give
to your thirty year old self I would
probably say think of the long game
because you freaked her out your I
freaked myself out so much being like oh
my god you know I have to do this I have
to do that I have to do this and you
know I've always lived my life with a
sense of urgency and sometimes that
works out in your favor sometimes you
watch it make bad you know quick
decisions and as I've gotten older I've
recognized that life just has its ups
and downs I mean the classic you know
Buddhist saying would be you know the
middle path you know you don't get super
excited and overconfident when something
really great happens for you and you
don't get completely depressed if
something bad happens for you and you
just have to understand that you know
life goes in these crazy waves and you
just hold steady and put one foot in
front of the other I love it and putting
one foot in front of the other eyes
effect that could be the the subtitle of
your latest film also if you could you
please let everybody know where they can
find
the film where they can find more
information online and then where they
can find you online and of course I will
link to all of this in the show notes
but what where can they learn more about
miru and more about you so I think the
best place to look is mera film.com
so Emmy are you film calm and that has a
little list of all the theaters and and
other information about the film and
then our handle on social media for
Instagram Twitter and Facebook are all
also mera film our app mera film and
we're releasing online in November I'm
iTunes so look for us there and then for
myself it's just Jimmy Cheng calm as we
all know documentaries kind of live and
die by word of mouth and hopefully
people have an opportunity to see it and
if they like it please share share this
Stoke that would be great yeah you guys
have to check it out Maru is spectacular
we will chat maybe another time about
how the hell you guys actually captured
footage in a lot of these situations I
think that's an entire entire
conversation in and of itself but folks
check it out it's very well worth the
time you know I love Docs and this is
the best one I've seen in a very very
long time so check it out if you want to
be inspired terrified pee your pants
just a little bit which is always it's
good every once in a while it's healthy
for your bladder and urethra you should
check it out
so Jimmy I really appreciate the time
man and you've inspired me to get my get
my pale lazy ass outside in much greater
volume in the coming year so for that I
thank you and thank you for having me
yeah man keep up the great work and I
will I will talk to you soon
all right thanks hey guys this is Tim
again just a few more things before you
take off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me and would you enjoy getting a
short email from me every Friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoyed this
podcast is brought to you by mizzen and
main don't worry about the spelling all
you need to know is this I have
organized my entire life around avoiding
fancy shirts because you have to iron
them you sweat through them they smell
really easily their pain-in-the-ass
mizzen and mane has given me the only
shirt that I need and what I mean by
that and Kelly Starrett loves these
shirts as well is that you can trick
people they look really fancy so you can
take them out to nice dinners whatever
but they're made from athletic sweat
wicking material so you can throw this
thing into your luggage in a heap or on
your kitchen table like I did recently
and then pull it out throw it on with no
ironing no steaming no nothing walk out
and you could probably wear this thing
for a week straight or make it your only
dress shirt and take it on trips for
weeks at a time never wash it it will
not smell you will not sweat through it
you got to check these things out so go
to four hour work week comm all spelled
out four hour work week comm forward
slash shirts check it out four hour work
week comm forward slash shirts and
you'll see some of my favorite gear
including the one shirt that I've been
traveling with this episode is brought
to you by trunk club I hate shopping
with a passion going shopping for fun to
me is like let's go do our taxes I don't
get it it's something that I have to do
but I don't like it at all and quite
frankly I'm not good at it I always end
up looking like I'm colorblind or
homeless or something like that
so ROI really sucky and as a result I
decided to try trunk club and I expected
to dislike it quite frankly but here's
how it works and here's why I'm now a
huge fan and just as a prelude the items
that I kept from them I've had more
compliments from random women on like
t-shirts and shorts and these funky
green shoes that I got than ever before
which proves that I don't know what I'm
doing and they do you go to trunk club
calm forward-slash Tim you answer a
couple of questions then you get
assigned a personal stylist so mine was
Robin then they send you a trunk full of
awesome stuff that they predict you will
like and look good in based on your
sizes preferences etc that they've
covered in this short phone call it was
really short to the point then this
trunk is delivered to your home it's
free of charge both ways so you only pay
for clothes that you keep if you keep
none of them that's fine you mail the
whole thing back with a prepaid label
they even include tape to shut the box
and you're good to go cost you nothing
there's no ongoing subscription this is
not a subscription service so only when
you ask for a trunk you will get a trunk
and I expected to keep maybe two items
out of eight you know I didn't want a
thousand things sent to me so I got
about eight things sent to me and expect
it to keep two because they give you a
preview online to show you what's coming
and then keeping four and I've been
traveling with those I've very
minimalist luggage but I've been
traveling for a couple weeks and I've
brought everything with me because it's
been so multi-purpose and so well
received it's kind of blowing my mind
quite frankly so trunk Club calm forward
slash Tim you get premium clothing great
advice for zero and work so it's a great
trifecta and the way they make money is
really easy I mean they buy high quality
clothing at volume and they just charge
you the normal retail pricing but
obviously they buy it at a cheaper price
so there's no tricks no hidden costs
it's really easy to be the best-dressed
man in the room or on the street so
their entire styling service is free for
now like I mentioned check it out trunk
club com forward slash Tim they also
have club houses so you can check that
out which is pretty cool so trunk club
com forward slash Tim and you can get a
trunk filled with sweet clothing very
easily that will make the ladies watch
you and make the men
to be you it is a good ROI and for
someone who's always hated fashion now I
can actually look fashionable with next
to no time expenditure so pretty sweet
trunk love calm forward slash Tim check
it out if you want more the Tim Ferriss
show you can subscribe to the podcast on
itunes or goto for our blog comm where
you'll find an award-winning blog tons
of audio and video interview stories
with people like Warren Buffett and Mike
Shinoda from Lincoln Park the books plus
much much more follow Tim on twitter at
twitter.com/dspacestv or on facebook at
facebook.com slash Tim Ferriss til next
time thanks for listening
[Applause]